ففي حديث الناس ليس هناك من استراحه ونسال
سؤالا بسيطا اليوم حول تحول كاس العالم
الى مونديال حراس المرمى على كل حال اكتمل
المربع الذهبي اربع فرق تتنافس على الكاس
واربعه حراس يتنافسون على القفاز الذهبي
كافضل حراس في البطوله العديد من حراس
المرمى في البطوله
الكرواتيه دومينيكلي باكوبيتش مثلا اصبح
بطلا في بلاده بعد تصده لركلات ترجيحيه
يابانيه وراء ركله برازيليه لكن بخلاف
تالق الحراس ظهرها ضعف المسددين البعض
يرجحنا الضغط النفسي عامل اساسي وانا
ركلات الجزاء اصبحت كابوسا للاعبين لويس
انريكي مدرب المنتخب الاسباني مثلا قال ان
لاعبين تدربوا على الف ركله جزاء والنتيجه
ان نفس اللاعبين اهدروا ثلاث ركلات امام
المغرب العملاق تحديدا تصدى لركلتين منها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بابتسامه عريضه كما اعتاد ان يظهر في
الصور يتحرك ياسين بونو بثقه ليلوذ عن
مرمى بلاده قبل انطلاق ركلات الترجيحيه
امام اسبانيا في دوري ال16 يتحدث مع خصمه
ويتخذ موقعه ويتصدى لركلتي ترجيح ويساعد
بلاده على التاهل لاول مره الى ربع نهائي
الممتعه
بعد مباراه اسبانيا التي امتدت اصلا لاكثر
من 120 دقيقه بخلاف الضغط النفسي المصاحب
لركلات الترجيح يتحدث مع الاعلام هو عن
براعته في التصدي لركلات الترجيح يقول ان
الامر ببساطه ما هو الى بعض من الحدث اكثر
ياسين بونو داخل الملعب والوداع خارجه لا
يثير ضجيجها في تحديات ناريه قبل المباراه
او ينتقص من خصمنا فقد يتصدر اسم العناوين
كبطل او حامي عرين الاسود او قاهر احلام
البرتغاليين رجل المباراه الثانيه على
التوالي في المونديال بعد اداء عظيم في
نصف النهائي لكنه يختار ان يهديها لزميله
يوسف النصيري صاحب هدف اللقاء الوحيد امام
البرتغال لكن بولو لا يريد الاكتفاءه هنا
يقول بعد مباراه البرتغال نحن هنا لتغيير
العقليه لقد غيرنا عقليتنا بالفعل والجيل
التالي سيعرف ان المغاربه يمكنهم صنع
المعجزات
على كل حال سالنا الجماهير في الدوحه
ضربات الجزاء هل هي اصعب على اللاعب الذي
يسدد ام على الحارس
استاذ سلطان الجاسم بدي اسالك بما انك
خبير رياضي ضربات الجزاء مين اصعب هل هي
على البضروفها اللاعب ولا الي بتلقاها
حارس المرمى
الي يكون عنده ثقه عنده برود عند نوع من
الصبر يعني شوف الزاويه الصح
اصعب بالنسبه لي يعني اكثر
[موسيقى]
الكره فقط
خمس ضربات جزاء بالاضافه اذا تمددات
لانه بقعد يفكر يجيبها جوا والي ما
يجيبهاش جول
كيف بدي اشوته بكون خايف يكون متوتر بخاف
انه الحاله سنه بده يصدها ما يصدهاش تطلع
بره بالعرضه فرغ من الباب كبير من اللاعب
بيشوفه صغير
الحارس
[موسيقى]
الرياضي محمد يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في
صباح العربيه من جديد احتقمت مباريات
الادوار خصوصا الحاسمه من مونديال قطر
لركلات الترجيح وضيعات جميعها في اطار
ضعيفه التنفيذ يعني كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
رغم تسديدها من قبل اللاعبين يعتبر
يعتبروا مهاره فنيه محمد
اولا شكرا على استضافه سعيد جدا بالتواجد
برفقتكم مره اخرى من الدوحه بخصوص ركلات
الجزاء اعتقد ان المشكل والمشكل نفسي
بالدرجه الاولى طريقه تعامل اللاعبين مع
الضغوط هناك ضغوط كبيره جدا على اللاعبين
في عالم كره القدم الحديث ربما في السنوات
الماضيه في العشريات الماضيه في الاجيال
الماضيه كره القدم كانت تعتمد اكثر على
المتعه يعني لا وجود تكتيكيه كبيره على
اللاعبين لا وجود لقيود اعلاميه كبيره على
اللاعبين لا وجود له قيود جماهيريه ايضا
الان كبرت اموال كره القدم ومعها كبرت همم
الضغوط وكبر الطموح والجماهير دائما تطالب
اللاعبين همم مردود اكبر لذلك اعتقد ان
التعامل اللاعبين مع ركلات الجزاء
والتعامل اللاعبين مع هذه الضغوط هو ما
ادى الى تضيع الكثير من ركلات الجزاء
شاهدنا كيف ضيع اليونان ميسي وهو اعظم
لاعب في همم كره القدم في العالم حاليا
ركله جزاء في هذا المونديال ااا شاهدنا
الكثير من اللاعبين الكبار يضيعون ركلات
الجزاء وفي المقابل نشاهد لاعبين مغمورين
يسجلون ركلات الجزاء هذا هو الفرق الفرق
في التعامل مع الضغوط النفسيه طيب محمد
محمد وقت مباراه البرازيل كرواتيا لاحظنا
انه حارس مرمى البرازيل كان كل الوقت يرمي
نفسه لليمين في اي لحظه يتم ضرب ركله جزاء
وكانه يقول للفريق الاخر يعني انا اعرف
تكتيكم لكن ما زبطت معه في وقتها هل فعلا
في رسم معين خطه معينه لركله الجزاء ولكل
فريق تميز خاص بها
اكيد اكيد شهدنا في الكثير من الاحيان كيف
يقدم مدرب حراس المرمى ورقه مثل ما فعل
عصام الحضري في كاس افريقيا الماضيه حين
قدم ورقه الى حارس مرمى المنتخب المصري في
ركلات الجزاء في مباراه من المباريات ااه
الورقه مكتوب عليها كل لاعب سيسدد الى اي
ناحيه سيسدد وهذا بالاعتماد على
الاحصائيات عصام الحضري بعدها صراحه مؤكدا
انه درس جميع لاعبي همم المنتخب درس جميع
المسددين المسددين ركلات الجزاء وفي اخر
المطاف نجحت الخطه والمنتخب المصري اا فاز
بفضل تصدي الحارس لهذه الركلات لذلك في
كره القدم الحديثه همم يعتمد المدربون
واللاعبون ايضا على الاحصائيات الحارس همم
همم دائما ما يدرس طريقه تسديد اللاعبين
المنافسين تقريبا اللاعبون المسددين
لركلات الجزاء معروفون سلفا لذلك الحارس
يقوم بدراسه كل لاعب على حدا واي الجهتين
يسدد همم لها هذا الحارس نعم
بطريقه عاليه جدا بدنيا هل باتو اليوم الى
مختصين لم يعد الامر مختصرا على الموهبه
الفنيه في تسديد ركلات الجزاء ولكن التاهي
النفسيه للسير الى منطقه الجزاء كما
اكيد اكيد اليوم لا يوجد اي فريق في
العالم او منتخب في العالم لا يملك في
طاقمه الفني طبيبا نفسيا او محضرا نفسيا
انصح القول يقوم بتحضير اللاعبين نفسيا
والتحضير النفسي لا يقل بتاتا اهميه
التحضير اللاعبي للبدنين بل في للاعبين
عفوا بل في الكثير من الاحيان يتفوق في
الاهميه على التحضر البدني للاعبين لذلك
كل اللاعبين يخضعون لجلسات نفسيه قبيل
المباريات الكبيره خصوصا في مثل هذه
المنافسات الكبرى مثل كاس العالم ولكن
تبقى همم هناك هبه ربانيه للاشخاص هناك
بالفطره هناك اشخاص اقوي الشخصيه بالفطره
همم قد لا يحتاجون حتى الى تحضير نفسه في
المقابل هناك لاعب كبار ولكنهم
همم ذو شخصيات ضعيفه لا يقوىون على تحمل
الضغوط ولا يعرفون الطريقه المثلى للتعامل
مع هذه الضغوط لذلك يضيعون الكثير من
الركلات يعني انا
خليني شغله يعني هل ممكن ان العامل النفسي
هو قد يكون الاقوى ويؤثر على من سيقوم
بضربه الجزاء يعني ان نلعب على فكره
النخير حارس المرمى بطريقه نفسيه هل هذا
هو الطرح اليوم وبناءا على ذلك من هم
الاقوى من ناحيه ركلات الجزاء خصوصا انه
تم حسم مبارياتين خلال كاس العالم من خلال
الفنتيس
الى غايه الان ابدا اييه ممن انتهيتي الى
غايه الان كرواتيا تثبت للمره الالف انها
المنتخب الاقوى في ركلات الجزاء تقريبا
اصبحت الطريقه المعتمده من المنتخب
الكرواتي امام المنتخبات الكبرى همم
كرواتيا تعلم تماما الفوارق الشسعه الان
بينها وبين منتخبات همم كبرى مثل البرازيل
لذلك خطتها المثلى هي تجر هذه المنتخبات
الى الادوار الاصوات الاضافيه ثم بعدها
الى ركلات الجزاء اين تتفوق على البقيه في
الشقه الاول من سؤالك اكيد هناك حرب نفسيه
دائما متبادله ليس من طرف اللاعبين فقط
ولكن من طرف حراس المرمى ايضا متبادل انه
شايف في الكثير من الاحيان حراس المرمى
وهم يتقدمون الى مسدد الركله من اجل
محاوله التاثير عليه نفسيا حدث في الكثير
همم من المباريات لذلك اعتقد ان الجانب
النفسي يلعب اهميه كبرى همم على اللاعب
وايضا على همم الحارس هذا هو ااا مربط
الفرس في ركلات الجزاء العامل النفسي اقوى
من الموهبه واقوى من القوه البدنيه للاعب
حداد
محمد امين بن شبير